all right Stephen
Stephen oh wait where are you from
where'd you grow up
um I'm from Delaware I grew up in um
Dover Delaware
um
I was Dover
it's a small tiny out of date town the
one the one time I've been in Dover
I remember watching a guy chase another
guy down the street with a baseball bat
and I think eventually I've never seen
two guys run so fast in my life but I
think he eventually caught him oh yeah
not that about describes Delaware
at least Dover
what was your family like Corona
um
distant all of us there was uh
what seven or eight kids
all in the same roof dad had to work two
jobs all the time never saw him
mom would her stepmom would work every
once in a while
um
cutting hair
and then you know she would go crazy
watching you know six kids seven kids
then a baby
until I started watching the babies and
I started cooking and helping
any rough stuff in your childhood
um when I was
nine
my mom
she she showed back up in our in our
lives
she's gone for what five years and then
um she was remarried and that was news
to us
and then um
you know everybody everybody's outside
everybody's having fun I thought I was
the only one in the in the house cooking
because I was making dinner for
everybody because I wanted to show my
mom you know hey look I can cook
but uh when I was
on the stove I [__] went to turn
around and my stepdad was there and put
his dick in my mouth
and that that was
traumatizing itself because at the time
I I put that right out of my mind
and pretended like it never happened
because even with therapy like
I was sure nothing like that had
happened and I didn't remember that
until a couple years ago when I got
sober
for the first time
and I'm like why am I always so jumpy
and then it's just like it all clicked
and came back to me and
was not something that was easy to deal
with you carried in your subconscious
all the time
but it still has a way of coming to the
surface doesn't it yeah even if you
don't remember it it seems
always
okay what kind of give you in high
school
I'm sorry what kind of kid were you in
high school
a quiet loner I always kept myself I had
a very very small tight-knit group of
friends
and then 12th grade it's like I was like
a completely different person I was
outgoing I had more friends you know it
started hanging out with people
and I branched out what changed
I think my
I think my weight
I think it's like well no I can't even
say that like it I was a fat kid from
fourth grade up
and then by 12th grade instead of me
being fed it just was it it evened out I
guess
and I wasn't like just rounding the gut
and so I guess that just gave me that
like little boost of confidence
and then
I went to right after high school and
went right to work
I tried to go to college I wanted to be
a math teacher I've known that since I
was a kid I wanted to be a math teacher
but uh went to college for two months
gave that up
gave that up for work
because I was more concerned with making
money than I was
about a career in the long run
when did drugs come into the picture for
you
two months after that
because once you have that much money
and you don't have that much time off
all you want to do is
Escape
and
drugs was the quickest way to get there
and I was raised and and firmly believed
all the way up until then that you know
drugs are bad
I refuse to do drugs until that point I
had
put down people who did drugs at that
point
I lectured my friends who did drugs at
that point
and then once I started it was
hate to say but like the greatest thing
that ever happened to me because
I found another way to to escape
what I thought was a shitty reality
because I started I started cutting real
bad
After High School
and like you got to the point where I
had to get 11 stitches in my arm right
here
because I just cut so deep
what was your drug
um your first drug at least
first drug was so much hats
um I think they're like a muscle relaxer
and I used to I used to get in so much
trouble with my with my cousin
I would just go over to his house and
his mom I guess she just didn't care
because she gave them to us
just for fun I guess
and then me and him would go you know
running around his neighborhood [__]
around [__] [__] up
you know start fires in the middle of
nowhere for no reason
and then after that
I didn't start drinking till I was 23.
and once I started drinking combined
with
Percocets at the time so I just started
those
all bad news
when did you come to Los Angeles
uh the first time it was maybe four
years ago
and it was the best thing that happened
to me I spent that year all I did was
drink
I got I got off a heroin I got off of
cocaine I got off to like everything
that that was literally dragging me down
in Delaware
and then I went back
and
went right back into the
right right back in the swing of the
drugs and then came back here
hoping that you know I'm away from it I
don't know where it's at out here I'll
be all right
no where there's a will there's a way if
you want to find drugs you will find
them
boy did I want to find them
have you been making money when you've
been on the streets
um
at first I would uh I would recycle I
would just go around collecting cans
collecting bottles I haven't collected
glass that's the honest way to make a
living on the streets and that's that's
how I wanted to do it until you know
there was just a day where I had spent
15 hours collecting everything and then
in the end it equaled out to three
dollars an hour
and then at that point I was just like I
I can't do this anymore I can't
and so I found a found a new way to make
money
it was new to me anyway so I would
you know go out and do what everyone
else does and steal items and sell them
you know to whoever I'll buy them
and
so far I've been lucky haven't gotten in
trouble before but boosting as they call
it yes
but I know my time's coming
I know that if I get caught again then
I'm almost certain to go to jail
and it's just it's not how I want to
live it's not how I picture my life
going
I'm not a criminal
but I am
how old are you
I turned 33 tomorrow
happy birthday thank you
what are you gonna do to celebrate your
birthday
I'm gonna try and go to the arcade
so one thing I wanted to do since I got
out here is go to an arcade and just
haven't had the time found away had the
money
so I'm just even if I just go and like
see some video games I think that'd be
all right
but is your drug currently
Fentanyl
opiates
I love
love my opiates but
fentanyl now because it's strong it was
Stronger way stronger than heroin
and
it's just it's what I feel my body needs
because
I've been I've been hit by five cars
I've been ran over by six
and it's it's affected my body in such a
way that I feel like I need
that pain relief why do you keep getting
hit by cars
uh
by walking in traffic
a couple times yeah it was my fault for
sure other times it was like
you know just pure accidents you know it
was a two of them were bicycle accidents
um
another time a cop was leaving the
casino and you know hit me going 55
miles an hour in the exit
somehow that was my fault
um my mom hit me
uh at the State Fair one uh one year
and then parked your car on my phone and
blame me for that
growing up my nickname was gimpy with my
family because I was I was always hurt
and that that's still True to this day I
am always hurt
you've been in love before
yeah
her name was Shelly
it's used to
the best thing that ever happened to me
and probably the one thing I regret the
most in my life
was
letting her go
not even letting her go making her go
how did you make her go
I had to I lied to her and told her my
feelings changed and and that you know I
didn't love her anymore that'll do it
she was
she she would have followed me in my
footsteps and done everything that I was
doing and at the time I had just started
getting into drugs like the heavier
drugs
and it should have done whatever it took
to stay with me even if it meant
snorting cocaine and
shooting up heroin
she'd have done it if it meant being
with me and I couldn't I couldn't let
her throw her life away I love me love
like that's hard to find
so it wasn't
wasn't gonna let her do that
I've talked to her one time since then
and I've dated one girl in the since
then it's been 10 years now
still think about her all the time do
you think
there's part of you that doesn't believe
you deserve something like that
[Music]
I feel like most of the time she was my
my one chance
at a at a happy good relationship
did you push it away
Oh I pushed it away and buried it
I don't even give my chance myself a
chance to to be happy to to love someone
anymore
I don't let anybody get close
like the most recent girlfriend I've had
she she knows nothing about me in my
life
and we've been together for
nine months
dear friends now
yeah
more acquaintances than friends but some
people
close enough to consider a friend
um
actually my my best friend from high
school he came out here at the same time
I did
or around the same time I did
but
you know drugs changed him he's a
different person now
so it's hard to even tell who he is
until you know he wants or needs
something then he's
you know my best friend again
it's funny how drugs have a way of
changing your
everything your moral compass your
your your personality your
you throw your dreams and your
all your loves out of the out of the
you just get rid of them and
figure out what hustle you can come up
with to get money for the next fix right
[Music]
um
sometimes it doesn't even matter who or
what you screw over someone like you get
high
that's a sketch it's sad scary thought
can you imagine getting your your old
self back
I always say that the one thing that uh
would I know it would force me to get
sober but it's also at the same time
it's like I want I want to get sober
forward the same reason as if I got
or if I had a child on the way
like I know for a fact I would I would
get sober because that's the one thing
I've wanted to do in my life is be a
good dad
and a good dad doesn't do drugs
but
I mean I've I've gone sober before it
didn't last long but I did do it and I
know I can
it's just a matter of finding that once
again
fentanyl such a hard drug to quit
[Music]
yeah I keep hearing it's it's ten times
worse than trying to quit heroin
but
I think when it comes down to it for the
right reason
it won't be as hard as
at least I hope it's not
was it hard adapting to living on the
streets
it's
no it was it actually got pretty easy
when uh when I did have a chance at
housing it was harder for me to readjust
being in society again
than it was to leave it
if that makes sense
like just trying to be a person again
showering every day brushing my teeth
all all that stuff like it became
foreign
you know after a certain amount of time
so when it came back to to doing all
those again and being in a shelter and
being inside
I just didn't know how to do it
what do you think people
that don't do drugs don't understand
about drug addiction
pretty much that
even if we do want to stop
we we can't not on our own
no matter how hard we drive there's no
way anybody can do it on their own they
everybody needs help
to stop
but they also got to want to
and we all do at some point
yeah I've done interviews with people
where they sit there and tell me they
want nothing more than to get clean and
get help and get straight and get their
lives back
and then 10 minutes later I see them
getting high around the corner yep
and honestly you know they probably
really did mean it yeah no I believe
they did
but that hold of the
drug is just so strong
is that fear of getting sick too
yeah once you start feeling feeling that
drug leave your system and you you know
it's not there anymore
you you get your body gets a little
scared
and it doesn't know how to react anymore
it's like a part of he's now missing
because it's been so long since you've
had it last can you describe what
withdrawal from fentanyl is like
very first thing I feel
body aches and they become more and more
intense
and then
you don't know if you're
freezing hot or burning cold
you can't tell you don't know which it
is
you can be you know
shivering and sweating your ass off
it's just
it is the most backwards asinine
feelings in the world
and then even with um like the nausea
the dog's just the worst because you
just you feel like you got to throw up
every second
but you can't
and it doesn't subside right not at all
it does not go away until you get that
next fix
do you need a whole bottle of Tums
trying to get rid of that option it
won't go nowhere
that's why people just can't
stick it out mm-hmm
you've had bad things happen to you on
the streets
no I I can't I can't say that any hands
um the worst that's happened is like I
got in a fight
holding my cat
but
out here no
I've been I've been lucky in that sense
but I also you know do my best to avoid
being in situations like that um
I've always been that type of person
how would you say your your years
being on the streets as a drug addict
has changed you
I'm I'm not as big a pushover as I used
to be that's for sure
I don't let I don't let as many people
talk down to me
like I'll stand up for myself where as
before I wouldn't
always let anybody say whatever they
wanted about me and just shrug it off
and I've come to appreciate
actual work
because like I said
boosting boostings for the birds
but so is recycling but
when I was recycling it felt
more rewarding
Stephen what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
how do I play it
be grateful for what you have when you
have it because you don't know
when it's gonna be when it's not going
to be there anymore
all right Stephen thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you I wish you
lots of luck out here I appreciate that
you have a great day man thank you